Donald Trump isn’t exactly known for thinking
in foreign policy details.
My foreign policy will always put
the interests of the American people and American
security above all else.
But recently, Trump got specific about something
important — NATO, the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization.
And what he said shocked everyone.
NATO is a military alliance between the U.S.,
Canada and a large chunk of Europe.
It began in 1949 as a means of deterring a
Soviet attack on Western Europe.
In Washington, the United States breaks
a 170-year-old tradition as it joins
eleven nations in the signing of the Atlantic
Defense Treaty.
Basically saying, "if you attack one of us, you'll get a response from all of us."
NATO has since grown to include 28 countries,
including former members of the Soviet Union.
It intervened to end the Bosnian War in 1995,
and responded to the 9/11 attacks with a decade-long
mission in Afghanistan.
The alliance has helped keep the peace
in the Northern Hemisphere for more than half
a century.
And now, Donald Trump has threatened to destroy
the whole thing.
So, Trump was in an interview with the New York Times on July 20.
And Sanger asks him...
Trump replies...
And then Trump says...
Trump is probably referring to the fact that
all the NATO countries have agreed to spend
2 percent of their GDP on national defense as part of the treaty.
The U.S. is one of just five countries
that met that benchmark in 2016.
Trump isn’t the first to call out countries
that haven’t.
The majority of allies are still
not hitting that 2 percent mark....everybody
has got to step up and everybody has got to
do better.”
But Trump is the first and only one to suggest
that our commitment to NATO should be contingent
on those spending levels.
And even his fellow Republicans are calling
him out.
Now, I have friends that serve in parliament in places like Estonia, that every day worry about the Russians
deciding that this is the time to re-annex and to take them back.
And comments like this are not only ill-informed, they're dangerous.
I, mean, it's the most successful military alliance in the history of the world.
I want to reassure our NATO allies that, should any of them be attacked, we'll be there to defend them.
And I'm willing to chalk this up to a rookie mistake.
But Trump isn’t backing down.
If Mitch McConnell says that, then he's wrong.
So all I'm saying is they have to pay.
So why is this such a big deal?
Because of the way that NATO works.
NATO deters attacks through something called credible commitment.
There’s no organization that can force the
United States to go fight for Estonia, Latvia
or Lithuania.
A country like Russia has to believe that
the United States is willing to intervene
even if it risks World War III.
That’s why political leaders of both parties
haven’t wavered from the commitment to defend
the NATO alliance.
And he used the NATO alliance almost as a transactional, business alliance.
So that is a complete break with American policy.
And Trump’s remarks come at a time when
NATO is particularly relevant.
Russia invaded Ukraine in 2014, even annexing
part of the country.
This came just six years after its invasion
of Georgia.
That’s why the New York Times asked him specifically
about the Baltic states: Estonia, Latvia,
and Lithuania.
Russia is getting increasingly aggressive
on its boarders, and if it seems like
the United States is wavering, Putin might
be more tempted to attack one of the Baltic
states as a part of a plot to destroy NATO.
And the Republican presidential candidate
has just invited him to try.